v j'ai vu alors il ya plein de trucs à
faire parce que tu est un peu rebelles
ces derniers temps aussi c'est pas
rebelle nantais part belle tête
c'est vrai maintenant parce que tout le
monde a parlé ton ton histoire la tat
par l'ida lisais dernièrement
et c'est vrai que tout le monde a repris
ce truc là tu avais dit alors on va on
va voir ce que tu as dit voilà sur alizé
keen'v on l'avait t'avais dit que tu
étais avec elle dont la côtoyer dans les
[ __ ] et c'est vrai dans le droit
turc de gocek et on peut alors à dix on
pourrait tout à l'heure et que voilà ça
se passait mal entre vous pour tes pas
exactement ça en fait c'est que si tu
veux pour reprendre le truc exact c'est
que j'ai du mal avec l'essence de la
personne parce que je les ai vues de mes
propres yeux alors on pourra me dire ce
qu'on voudra que j'ai vu de mes propres
yeux
en fait nous on rentrait tous nos
recettes les stars tous ceux qui t'ont
qu'ils ont fait pour te lire on tousse
par l'entrée des artistes
mais l'entrée principale cela il ya tous
les gens qui nous attend dès qu'ils ont
fait les photos et elle avait tendance à
prendre une entrée un peu dérobés et moi
ça me gênait pas ce que c'était des gens
qui étaient là bienveillant qui était
juste venu pour faire des photos avec
nous et donc je me suis un peu emporté
la forme n'y ait pas effectivement la
forme n'est absolument pas mais le fonds
liés dire que c'est vraiment on m'a
demandé tu t'en porter un poids voulu en
parler comme ça parce que j'étais à la
radio et puis j'avais co et puis tu vois
quoi si je te parlais à toi en fait
chaque os x et oui moi comme l'ami après
oui c'est bon c'est regrettable
effectivement mon chef chez nous je vous
dis tout de suite le mot kaunas n'a rien
de 2,2 me jean c'est à rouen c'est ont
tout est une [ __ ] le cndd moi même
surtout moi d'ailleurs
non en fait c'est que si tu veux c'est
je comprends que ça a pu choquer parce
que c'était très méchamment dit mais
dans le fond on m'a demandé quelqu'un
que j'aimais pas je n'aime pas pas grand
monde c'est parce que vie c'est un amour
de mecs tout le monde c'est vrai et même
plus particulièrement valérie d'ailleurs
sur valérie il ya une rumeur qui raconte
que la chanson cela j'aimerais trop quel
même match
ce titre voila j'aimerais trop
qu'elle-même moselle d'amérique alors et
il paraît paraît qu'à la base il paraît
que tu ne s'était pas exactement les
paroles dans son rigoler il donne
vraiment cru que c'était pour valérie
intéressés pour valérie les noms ne
connaissez pas encore et essai mais qu'
il courait le long
il est super bon dans le sont parsemés
çà s'adapte ça date ces dégâts c'est ce
sont là que j'aime chez keen'v oui mais
c'est pas su la nouvelle après merci et
au décalage horaire dans le dos on danse
on danse à son album d'aujourd'hui oui
on retrouve ses sonorités mais dans
l'album exactement voilà merci à l'étude
en un instant une nouveauté doc gynéco
michel faire cuire les lacs du connemara
non mais c'est vrai et c'est vrai qu'on
repousse ses sonorités ses sonorités
qu'on kiffe ces voix là c'est cette voie
là c'est festif c'est tout ce qu'on aime
alors qu'on keen'v et il ya une rumeur
qui dit moi je peux pas le dire parce
que il paraît que le titre à la basse et
pas que j'aimerais trop qu'elle-même
mademoiselle valérie ya eu deux versions
s'était coincé la vérité bah je peux pas
le dire la télé c'était quoi c'était
j'aimerais trop là haut ça rime avec man
avec barbie dans le mari bancaire oui
bon c'est vrai trop laquelle
mademoiselle valérie non je vois ça
passe pas ça non c'est pire non c'est
pas vrai c'est pire les news sont aussi
vulgaire non c'est quoi ça voila
j'aimerais trop la fête on a voulu faire
un délire où c'était on allait plus
vulgairement dans le truc hein d'accord
les deux marchés je pense que même avec
plus de succès mais tu sais que même
leonardo dicaprio départ games of new
york il avait débuté
[Rires]
je connais les eaux du nil ou d'ailleurs
je n'embrasse keen'v thérapie nouvel
album
ok merci